we've now got more details on cyberpunk
2077
gameplay and also an anime animal
crossing new horizons has an awesome new
update on the way this summer that's
gonna let us hop right back in the water
and what does optimize for xbox series x
really mean
well we're going to take a look at that
today too i'm persia and you reach your
safe state for thursday
june 25th
[Music]
the first night city wire live stream
just went down this morning which means
we now have more information on
cyberpunk 2077 gameplay and
their other project cyberpunk
edgerunners which is actually an anime
we saw a new trailer made entirely of
footage from the game's prologue which
included things like
badlands which is a desert district
outside of the city and ways you can
travel around badlands
and also a metal monster called atom
smasher
there's also a gameplay mechanic called
brain dance which can be used for
various things in the game such as
prisoner rehabilitation
therapy movies and even adult content
but using this mechanic means you'll be
able to rewind fast forward and move
your camera around other people's
memories to get more information on the
story
cyberpunk edgerunners however is coming
to netflix in 2022
and is going to be in the universe of
cyberpunk 2077
but will include nothing but original
characters and its own storyline which
is going to be pretty interesting too to
see how the world of cyberpunk
evolves before our eyes a new update is
coming to animal crossing new horizons
which is going to help us have a little
bit
more fun in the sun this summer the
first
part of the summer update arrives on
july 3rd which will allow you to swim
and dive into the ocean like a new leaf
there are underwater creatures like
starfish and anemones to find that you
can donate to the museum
and you'll also be able to meet some new
friends along the way
pascal the red sea otter will take your
trades of scallops for new mermaid set
diy
recipes and so much more and there's
even a pirate version of gulliver washed
up on the shore
even though we're not exactly sure what
his changes are gonna be
just yet the second half of the update
is set for august so
make sure you cool off dive into the
ocean and
get ready for what the next update has
in store
optimized for xbox series x is a label
we're going to be seeing on games once
the next gen consoles are finally here
but what does that really mean this
means that optimized gains are going to
support three key features
ray tracing up to 120 fps and near
instant loading times
some of these enhancements are thanks to
directx 12 ultimate support and a
current list of all the optimized games
are on gamespot.com right now
some notable games that are going to be
optimized are assassin's creed valhalla
and halo infinite
but it's worth noting that not just
next-gen games are going to be optimized
gears 5 and yakuza like a dragon are
also optimized
and kind of shows microsoft's commitment
to backwards compatibility
so what games are you hoping are going
to be optimized
let me know that's a wrap on our news
today you guys thank you so much for
tuning in
but don't forget we are still smack-dab
in the middle of play for all which is
our multi-week charity event that we are
hosting
all summer long to raise money for black
lives matter and kova 19 relief efforts
if you haven't had a chance to tune in
no worries we're still live every single
day between 12pm and 2pm pacific time
and we're covering things like game
reveals and announcements and even doing
some fun stuff
with our friends across the industry we
covered the cyberpunk livestream this
morning and tomorrow we're playing
rocket league with naomi kyle
so that's just a little bit of all the
things we're doing during play for all
and we're hoping that you tune in and
help us
support amazing causes i'm pershing you
can follow me on twitter at persia
underscore xo and make sure you reach
your next safe state
on monday i'll see you guys next time
you